these meetings are unannounced to ensure
security as top ranking officials from
NATO countries visit Kiev with pledges
of continued support
your pain of what's happened and we um
resolution which is the resolution that
you want to require
one year ago Ukraine's push against
Russia resulted in Moscow losing around
a half of the territory it seized since
its February Invasion this year with
Russian troops digging in kiev's
counter-offensive has slowed down but
NATO Chief Yen stoltenberg says Ukraine
was gradually gaining ground
every meter
that Ukrainian forces regains
is a meter that Russia loses
contest
ukrainians are fighting for their
families their future their freedom
Moscow is fighting for Imperial
delusions
stoltenberg announced two and a half
billion dollars in additional support
but sometimes politics can get in the
way last week a dispute over grain
Imports LED Poland to announce it as
stopping arms deliveries to Kiev the
problem was resolved but it served as a
reminder that Ukraine can't take
European help for granted
we'll keep on handing weapons to Ukraine
but this Handover which was a principle
is now going to be an exception I insist
it means we will keep on handing over
but only when we do not have other
Solutions
NATO's latest Aid package includes a
billion euros in contracts with European
arms dealers that help has been crucial
for Ukraine's fight but Europe's
ammunition stockpiles are running low
and it's an open question where the
Western production especially of
artillery shells can keep up with its
Ukrainian allies needs
Dimitri medvedenko Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera